most car makers are designing vehicles
to be environmentally friendly and low
on emissions with the a3 e-tron howdy is
taking the next step in this direction
this is the first out II model with
plug-in hybrid technology
Vons ultimen her car Chester asked why
should people drive hybrid cars there
are a couple of reasons he says for one
eighty percent of drivers cover fewer
than 50 kilometers a day that's the
range of this car
it's almost people need another reason
is money driving fifty kilometers in a
conventional gasoline powered car costs
around four euros 50 with this car and
the current electricity price 50
kilometres costs one euro seventy five
item price fished or liters by item oil
on film and dippity cent bank it's this
Evie button is used to select various
driving modes for example driving on
electric power alone or driving very
quietly I can also save the battery
charge or increase it if I'm going to
drive around town it might be important
for me to be co2 neutral and make less
noise kind of go I should put it yet
these are the Audi a3 e-tron is a
plug-in hybrid that means you can charge
the battery at home or wherever there's
an outlet you open this here and stick
in the plug nine Stickney well in doubt
this at home on a 220 volt outlet
charging takes around three hours and 45
minutes with an industrial power outlet
it takes around an hour and I have less
Howdy's engineers had to put on their
thinking caps to get the car to switch
on the go from it's electric drive to
the combustion engine
Kanoe some of us in the Audi product
marketing manager Ham on Feb ik says
that the problem was solved by mounting
the electric motor between the
combustion engine and the gearbox as we
can see everything is quite compact
image here is the dual mass flywheel and
then the electric motor don't come to a
machine efficient there's also a clutch
installed between the combustion engine
and the electric motor that separates
the two motors fan and con went on
compass and there's the standard six
gear s-tronic dual-clutch gearbox to run
the subkey boxes
classify tige three main strands occur
on electric drive the a3 e-tron goes
from 0 to 60 kilometers an hour in 4.9
seconds for the top speed of 1 over 30
kilometers an hour when the combustion
engine kicks in the top speed shoots up
to 220 - howdy says the model average is
1.5 liters of fuel per hundred
kilometers the Hippolyta Sarkar tester
adds another row of a detail the whole
system puts out 350 Newton meters which
makes for a relaxed driving experience
the a3 electrics each run badging on the
front and the rear is the first
difference to the other a3 s we notice
the situation is much the same inside
the e-tron badging chrome and matte
colors give the a3 e-tron a futuristic
feel
thank you so he does Pathan our tester
tells us there's also a smartphone app
that allows drivers to access card data
they can also turn on the
air-conditioning or the heat on and off
from outside the car and most
importantly they can see how much juice
is left in the battery here we can see
that it has 13 kilometers worth left
absolutism the trunk is spacious despite
the battery in gas tank only the spare
tire had to make way been seen Tonka so
no Hammond Fairbank tells us that the
gas tank is where the battery usually is
it was moved back to between the rear
tires this is organized it's a so-called
pressure tensioning fumes are created in
the tank and they need to be vented if
you're driving electrically the
combustion engine kicks in now and then
to use these fumes otherwise too much
pressure would build up in the tank so
the car can't do entirely without gas
our verdict
my father said furchester was very
impressed he was surprised how well the
technology worked although it's
extremely complex this technology has a
price tag of thirty seven thousand nine
hundred euros but he thinks that's money
well spent
ma let's get this all good angle eked
the Audi a3 e-tron goes on the market in
Germany in fall 2014